- Can I ask a question?
- Um hmm.
- If you can't get these
across state lines,
how did you do it?
- (laughs)
(upbeat music)
- I took a quick road trip
from New York to Montreal
this weekend in the pouring rain.
I brought back a few items that you just
can't find stateside, just
so my coworkers can try 'em.
They better like 'em.
- [Group] Surprise!
- Yes.
- Oh!
- Yes!
These are like legit banned.
- Kendra's surprised.
- Not for resale in the
United States. Damn!
- Here you go.
- Is there gonna be a
prize when we open it up?
- Am I gonna choke on camera?
- Offhand, I don't know
what this is about.
- Ooo.
- Mmm.
- So, I don't understand how
people are getting injured
when it's literally in another egg.
- I'm trying to go for a child's bite.
- Do it. Ready. Go.
- (mumbles)
- Oh.
- I bit the thing and I
couldn't bite any farther.
There was no more biting.
Oh my gosh, there's like
things. What?
- Yeah.
- I thought it was just a
toy. There's like accessories?
- The toy is not the egg.
- What is this, ChapStick inside?
That would be nice, though.
You eat it, and then you
"oh, my lip's a little chapped."
- We have plenty of toys
like this in America
that kids choke on.
- Well I just think because
it's coming in the chocolate,
they're like this whole thing--
- Is edible.
- Must be something that
I can eat right now.
- Do Canadian kids not choke on plastic
and choke on these things?
Why can they have it and we can't?
- I think Canadian kids
just might be smarter.
In the long run.
(upbeat music)
- Oh, it's a shot!
- We're getting drunk.
- Ooo!
- It smells like, oh my God, is this...
- It smells like licorice.
- This is Absinthe.
- Oh God.
- Are you trying to make
us black out at work?
- Oh. Okay.
- Oh. Ew.
- Woo! It's like, oh my God!
- Ooo.
- (coughs)
- It tastes like fireball at
first, and then it just goes
to straight burning. And then
it goes back to Jager Bomb.
- Please drink with extreme caution.
- Isn't this the stuff that
Shakespeare used to get sauced
on, or something like that?
- I'm okay with that being banned.
- Don't bring this shit over here.
Keep this shit in Ontario. Montreal.
I don't need this shit.
- Canada is known universally
as the nicest country,
so why would there be
things that Canada allows
that other places don't allow?
Free healthcare. I don't know, Absinthe.
- I think Canada is trying
to give us a little time out.
They're like, look, you're
wilding down there, down South.
So we got these good things
over here. You can't get none.
Sorry. But that's what happens
when you're in time out.
(upbeat music)
- Wow.